I was working 24 7 365. that all came
crashing down I was in a very low place
and now I'm full-time property investor
I mean how much are you charging for
that on average three thousand five
thousand we've done ten thousand pound
deals I mean most people don't own that
in a month the person that I bought the
house off he even invested 30 grand into
it no the sky's the limit but the owner
gave you money to buy his
his stuff really works
Muhammad Allah how you been I'm
brilliant thank you you've absolutely
smashed it um and I've loved watching
your journey on social media yes
definitely uh worked hard for it
um yeah definitely been putting myself
out there getting involved doing that
HML conversion yeah yeah it's uh when
you actually do things you learn so much
along the way yeah and it's been an
amazing journey yeah I remember being
drawn to you when we first met because
we met at a business conference yeah MMI
and I think I just thought this dude man
he's got something about him and we
connected to there and we've worked
together since and you've done a whole
bunch of deals so why don't you just
summarize what were you doing before you
got into property I had a taxi company I
had restaurants I had takeaways and I
was working 24 7 365. yeah I was I was a
workaholic that all Came Crashing Down
2017 we lost the operator's license in
the taxi game
um so I I call all this a blessing in
disguise my daughter was born at the
time as well yeah it was time to learn
something new and do something different
and your your energy and the things that
you were saying out there and really
brought me back to life you know
um and I thought right yeah you know
um I'll go to university learn something
for three years five years and then
become
a doctor whatever and that's it but when
you learn property entrepreneurship
business the sky's the limit yeah
um and the the people the environment
that you created was just uh absolutely
brilliant for me it took a little while
for you to get your first deal though
with us didn't it it took a good few
months it did it did and you were
complaining a little bit about oh it's
no one wants to buy deals it's a bit
tricky a big thing was my own mind frame
and where I was at when you've worked 10
12 years of your life hardcore or
something and you know all of a sudden
you have to dismantle everything you've
done it has an effect on your head and
the things that you're saying it you
know you're gonna get that anger out and
you carry that anger with you and when
you're carry in the anger with you
you're thinking negative of everything
that that comes around you right at that
time you know I was in a very low place
um mentally I was moaning I mean you
still moaning a little bit no no I'm
very positive now you are very positive
now but you can people it's quite easy
to moan because ninety percent of the
things that we see in social media and
see in the world in the news is is crap
yeah so we become that crap magnet right
that 10 of people the entrepreneurs the
businessmen a program to no I don't
taking crap I stop the crap I don't take
that in and I've got a train my brain to
gain and I've got to see the positive in
everything yeah you know you've got to
put a block on on the crap that's out
there yeah you know it just drags you
down but bad new sales doesn't it so
even even if I do a YouTube video If I
put something negative in the title yeah
it will get a hundred times the views
and I think in the same way with the
with the TV and mainstream media they
know if they say oh there's a great
thing that's happened or oh there's a
new school in this area and the No One
Cares but if they say oh the school just
got burned down yeah then it's suddenly
everybody wants to buy the newspaper so
these businesses these big media
companies they're always going to spin
things negatively if they say oh this
person's really rich and he's helping
lots of people no one cares but if I
said this person's really rich and we
think he's doing tax fraud woof it's a
big story so because of that we're
surrounded constantly by negativity
negative people negative media negative
news stories and I know you just had you
know you've closed your business down
what do you think changed between you
struggling to sell your first deal and
thinking man this isn't happening now
you're selling loads of deals you've
done your own Financial Freedom
challenge you're you're buying houses
you're selling houses like what do you
think the chat was it just mindset or
was it skill mindset skill when I was
training I didn't know much as I left
the training I learn and learn and learn
use social media lots of groups out
there confidence has grown yeah
confidence doesn't grow in just one day
one week two weeks three three months
six months 12 months yeah you know
confidence grows I'm well 2019
2022 now my confidence is back I know
what I'm talking about when it comes to
property I spoke to many many many
people all on different levels you know
now I know well professional property
investor yeah I know what I'm talking
about and now your full-time property
investor full-time part-time yeah I like
to call it uh like a retirement job you
know but yeah full-time property
investor great deals always come my way
you know the Mantra you know I'm a
property investor great deals always
come my way I've been saying that and
they do yeah and they do people are
always contacting me I've got this I've
got that what do you think you know and
the great deals do come our way talk to
me about what deal selling is because I
want to know how does how do you do it
how does it work how do you find
investors how do you close the deal what
is the product what is deal selling so
deal selling
we go out there we find deals all day
long so we find a deal we run the
numbers due to due diligence we
um check all the comparables in the area
and package it up ready for an
investment so you negotiate the price we
negotiate the price we secure it and we
run all the due diligence we make sure
that the deal is a good deal right
because the thing is there's hundreds of
thousands of properties available if you
go on right move yeah and you don't
really know what you're doing yeah
there's hundreds of thousands so having
somebody find a good deal negotiate it
go out there on a Tuesday afternoon and
view it in the rain yeah the age of the
agent put together a management company
the whole cabang I mean how much are you
charging for that on average obviously
um three three thousand five thousand
we've done ten thousand pound deals how
would you justify charging 10 grand for
a deal at four service accommodations uh
in a block two and a half thousand
pounds a deal and we ran all the new
number as all the due diligence was done
we got paid we got paid ten thousand
pounds in the bank whoa whoa this stuff
really works most people don't own that
in a month no and you can just make it
just from bang one good deal you can you
can you've got to have that mindset
you've got to have that training you've
got to understand the industry you've
got it because imagine if you got into a
plane and there's a pilot there and the
pilot was like my first day today yeah
you know all right okay don't worry
though I've watched a lot of YouTube
videos you're not going to trust your
lot you're going to put your life in the
hands of somebody and in the same way
when someone's putting their life
savings yeah in the hands of somebody
they want to know that person knows what
they're doing they've been trained
they've got good relationships with the
agents they know how to stuck a deal
they know how to do proper due diligence
before they'll pay and of course you
know you presumably you have a calling
off period right yeah of course if
you're selling a property yeah you're
gonna say look you've got maybe 14 days
to go do your own checks get a survey on
it and then if you're not happy you'll
get a refund but it just saves the
investor so much time and aggro if
they're a busy doctor working in London
and they want to invest in Manchester
just the petrol alone and going back and
forth and often viewings um you get
examples or they're viewing councils an
hour before and people haven't got the
time so they'd rather pay you three
grand I've had my investors look at a
deal and then not go ahead with this
deal because it was uh whatever uh
reason it was in a bad neighborhood or
whatever your neighbors are this side
that side and you know if it's even if
it's a bad neighborhood houses do get
rented out yeah and they've not taken
that deal and then they've seen
something else that's come on my list
and they've been quiet about that and
and then they've gone with that but they
missed out on that one and the time six
months down the line they've they've
come back and said oh well I'll go for
this one they missed out on all that
missed out on like rent time is money
Investments or Investments it's like to
find a deal now we're in the trade now
we've got so many cold sources that work
with us we've got so many people agents
calling us up do you want this do you
want that we built that Network for one
to go and build that Network it takes
takes time yeah and energy
um again training as well you know it's
important to know what you're talking
about because you you invested on the
full Academy so you drop like what like
12 12 Grand 12 Grand in yeah 12 Grand
hopefully well spent oh yeah brilliant
yeah what would you say the biggest
things that you learned over that 12
months were
um due diligence due diligence and
reading your contracts
um personal development yeah you know I
I'm a big believer in personal
development I always believe first of
all you've got to develop yourself
personally because if you're going to be
a millionaire you've got to know how
millionaire will operate and how are you
going to handle everything yeah
um you've got to understand the business
world the market changes all the time
interest rates are going up all the scam
greens going on in the news and the news
oh you know and the pound today the
pound is uh so weak to the dollar and
all this you've got to keep in touch
with that yeah and then obviously
property I've got the education on the
property side of things these three
things things in my opinion are the most
important things number one you've got
to start with yourself personally and
you've got to have that Vision
meditate and find that vision of where
you want to be what you want to do and
focus on one two things that you like
yeah choose that right thing that's
right for you and go forth that because
you already had a few properties when
you came on the Academy I did I did
these were without education properties
so I had the money I just put it into
the property thank you very much let it
grow yeah and but when you work out your
Roi and you know you work out
um how to do things properly it's a
different story altogether yeah it's
about right actually well if I didn't go
for that and I went for someone like
this then I would have got more more
money back on the money that I'm
spending because now you're doing a lot
of hmos service accommodation yeah well
I mean hmos are crazy because I an
average an average place in Manchester
Mark right now a small house two bedroom
three bedroom house 600 Quid 700 quid a
month yeah correct but you'll rent a
room out for 500 quid yeah so it's like
why don't you just rent it out room by
room and checked a couple thousand or
service accommodation yeah if you went
out on a nightly basis yeah as long as
you do your due diligence properly yeah
you can get three or four times as much
profit and you've not got tenants you've
got guests you've got tax advantages
it's just it's just crazy well I think
I've done all of the all of the things
that you've taught me in this one one
deal apart from the least option a bit
the brr uh I bought a house we we refill
this is your most recent purchase this
is uh Wigan project yeah okay yeah so
what house and we refurbed it
number one the deal selling it was to be
sold to an investor uh Netherlands
investor
everything was done loan agreements
ready to sign and at the last minute he
pulled out of the deal I sat there with
the solicitor and he pulled out what did
he pull out I don't know he must have
got cold feet something whatever got
nervous nervous something in the
negative media got him yeah yeah
um so I was like damn this is the last
minute we've got uh to for me to get
this Overland I've got this problem that
problem that problem that problem to
solve
and as you do as an entrepreneur boom
right first problem right I need to I
need to get a two-week extension because
I do exchange contracts for my investors
oh damn right so I was like I speak to
that solicitor they said no
so it's all right oh my God he's not
letting me do it I'll tell you what I'm
gonna go and find the guy that owns it
and now what I knew was he lived on this
road a few doors down so I knocked on
three doors and I found him
so to Dave
I'm in a bit of a pickle here I need a
two-week extension because yeah fine no
problem
foreign
brilliant your solicitor said no but
you're all right okay brilliant so he
found his solicitor and said yeah not a
problem it can have his two-week
extension that was one problem solved
then we had to rate some Finance
again picked up the phone we raised the
finance how did you raise the finance so
quick well we've got a list we've got a
list of investors a couple of the
investors put some money in I broke it
down
um I think I was aiming to raise about
45 40 Grand something like that I think
at the time I broke it down I got 10 000
off this person you're gonna love this
one the the person that I bought the
house off he even invested 30 grand into
it for me no yeah the owner of the house
the owner owner of the house saw what I
was doing we became friends we went for
a meal and everything you know what and
so the owner gave you money to buy his
house off of I got the buying bit done
and a 30 grand on the refurb side of
things dude you're a genius how much did
you give him back did you pay him a
fixed rate six or eight ten percent so
you said you have to support your house
I want 30 grand to refill it I'll give
you 10 back yeah it was done a bit
differently but yeah well we went for a
meal which we chatted about
um as I said look this is what I'm doing
do you fancy doing this you know
from the sale he gave you back yeah yeah
oh man he's become a great friend as
well now as well you know how important
is that networking and relationships
vital vital it's very very important so
you bought the house for how much 105
000. so you bought it because your
investor pulled out so you bought it for
105. yeah you refurbed it how much was
the total refurb at that time we were
calculating that it was going to cost
about 120 140 000 we were doing a seven
bed conversion and as I went in and
looking at everything that had happened
I thought you know what I'll just do a
family home four bedroom family home
island kitchen and all that I'd do a
simple job on it and move on to the next
one agree the price for the Builder I
think it was about 37 000 pounds
brilliant I thought right that's all
dead manageable we could do that is
strip the building I'm looking at it
better I'm thinking oh I could put a
room there room there and I can have my
six bedroom HMO I could earn me 37 000
pounds a year
um rent I wonder how much extra it would
cost if I save on the kitchen island
kitchen and and things like that the
doors they need to change from normal
doors to fire doors we need to put some
ensuites in we'll save here and put it
there and it got to 52
995 pounds okay so I was juggling the
money I was thinking right I've taken
that much there that much there I need a
little bit more because I'm gonna have
to furnish it all and things like that I
thought okay let's uh let's let's see
what the credit cards people are saying
these days I went online and that beer I
raised 13 Grand
I've got 13 Grands worth of cars there
yeah available to me so what is it now
like a six bed eight job it's a six bed
HMO now and you just had a bricks and
mortar valuation what did it come out in
it 210
000. oh mate that's awesome now that's
brilliant because
we were predicting 198 State agents were
saying to me normal residential 190. now
coming at 210 on a bricks of water boom
have they taken into account the
commercial aspect no no not yet you're
going to refinance it at 210 are you
gonna wait oh man I'm gonna wait I'm
gonna challenge that
I'm going to challenge that because
beforehand I've already spoken to
another surveyor and he's he's saying
the commercial valuation anything from
240 to 280. yeah of course so I know
it's there I just got to challenge the
way this guy's word in his valuation and
I've got to put another valuation
forward except like 100 Grand profit
then yeah but even if even at 210 you
could refinance that and you're gonna
pull out 157
000. so you're gonna pull out all your
money and then and then what about
profit how much is that profit gonna
clean you with a HMO I'm going to be
netting anything from 1500 to 1800 yeah
um a month
whereas if I go down the service
accommodation room our projections are
saying that we'll net between two and a
half thousand pounds a month on a 50
occupancy so even at 50 you're going to
make turn-offs profit yeah damn exactly
and you're going to pull out all your
money I'm gonna pull out all my money
and do it all over again so you'll be
left with a basically a free house yeah
making two and a half Grand a month yeah
that's incredible and that was a deal
that you wanted to pass to an investor
are you glad that it fell through yeah
blessing to describe so talk to me about
being a deal sourcer then because being
a deal sourcer opens you up to joint
ventures it opens you up to investors
which means if you come across a deal
rather than selling it you can raise the
finance yeah it basically you're getting
paid to find deals so if you get the
absolute Cherry deals you can keep them
yourself exactly Cherry deals you can
keep them yourself as you can see there
was a cherry deal there and I was trying
to give to an investor yeah it's
brilliant and everybody knows I'm a deal
sauce everybody knows
um you know my 25 years of experience my
social profiles you know it's real it's
raw I'm in the hot tub sometimes doing
my videos it is what it is you recently
did a Financial Freedom challenge yeah
talk to me about that because I'm a
massive believer in putting yourself
under time limits yeah something that we
do within the academy on the on the
programs rather than just teaching we'll
say here's what you do then I'll be like
now watch me do it and I'll be on the
phone doing it and then I'll say right
you've got one hour yeah go get a deal
and it's when you're under that pressure
yeah and it is stressful because it's
like oh but if you're not stressed and
if you're not stretched you're not
growing and you won't do it so when I
saw that you were putting yourself under
a seven day challenge yeah and you were
saying right I'm gonna go like like
crazy you're working with what was his
name the guy Liam Taylor you and Liam
went out on the road seven days what did
you guys achieve in a week we did we did
we smashed it um so at first we went a
foam bashing you get your 100 nose we
put it down to 100 notes before you get
one uh yes to a viewing on for service
accommodation so we got a couple of
viewings got there and then they go they
don't allow service accommodation they
don't allow corporate lets so then right
okay we're in the area so we went
knocking on some estate agent Stars we
walked into this estate agent at first
the estate agent was saying no
um you know we don't do corporate and
then the owner of the estate agent came
came out but I'm just refurbing these at
this house up and making it four
Apartments straight away there and then
we went around to the house weighed it
all up with him and and we saw that
brilliant this will this will work
absolutely brilliant so that we saw that
we went to Sheffield we traveled all
over the country we've got deals here
deals there deals there then we came
back packaged them up writing it all out
and um getting them ready to sell to
investors how much money did you make I
think it was about 18 000 pounds
altogether in a week in a week and when
you see that money in your bank account
you're like wow and it goes to show what
you can do when you put yourself under
time pressure what would you say about
in terms of areas where's your main
patch where you're doing deals I really
like Wigan I really like Wigan I've
actually stayed in the house and done
bits and you know know the area quite
well now and so personally I like wiggin
if I can get a couple more around there
I'm quite happy with that how do you
grow your investor list to sell it to
sell deals to well you've got to give
value to people you've got to share your
Journeys and people see what you're
doing you know I put a video of me paint
in a fence on reels and I'm like this
has hit 5 000 likes this is 10 thousand
views and things like that I'm like wow
I gotta keep doing and I've started
doing more and more reading social media
is a good tool absolutely amazing it's
unbelievable yeah um there's so many
people just watching scrolling scrolling
scrolling even I've done it I've
scrolled scroll scrolled and I've just
the screen time's like five hours today
and I'm like oh I need to be on the
other side I need to be making content
rather than watching content yeah and
that's one of the things that I was
taught you know on one of the programs
that I did with yeah marketing Market
because ultimately property investment
is a business you need to be able to
Market your products you need to be able
to Stage the property as well yeah you
need to be able to sell yeah you
constantly turn into estate agents to
investors also to tenants yeah you need
to be able to run the operation you need
to have a smooth operation systemize
everything yeah you need to understand
Finance Tax bookkeeping it's business
your house is your product and your
tenant is your customer how many crash
courses do you think you've been to Ma
uh until I got banned
[Laughter]
[Music]
20 30 of your crash courses what what is
it about because obviously we've got the
academy where we have mentoring and a
very Advanced Training yeah but the one
pound events people think oh it's only a
pound it won't be very good yeah but
they're pretty good they're very good
the energy the training you know the
value every time you go I learn
something new yeah you know watching you
and master at his works you know all
these people that you do help you know
all this anybody that's watched a Samuel
Lee's video has taken in something yeah
and a little seed's been planted in the
back of their heads right now it's down
to them what happens with that seed do
they water it or did you just let it die
yeah you know but Samuel leads is in
their head and Samuel leave keeps giving
value keeps giving content keeps working
his ass off right and going up and down
the country to help people learn yeah
and earn and grow and make their lives
financially do you think one of the
reasons that you've been so successful
though is because you are you're very
coachable you're always learning aren't
you you're a massive believer being a
student and I am as well we met at a
training program that wasn't mine
exactly I was on someone else's course
and I bumped into you there yeah so do
you think that one of the reasons you're
being so successful might be that
continual growth mindset learning never
ends doesn't matter how old you are you
can still learn right and it's it's
vital to keep learning the more you
learn you grow and keep growing if
you're not growing your day yeah so grow
you know even with 25 years of business
experience doing this project I've
learned so much the the first building
inspector told me I need a soundproof
test due into it we did a soundproof
test
and it failed
now only by one decibel here and two
decibels in that room but it meant I had
to spend another couple of grand to get
this right
then the second building inspector came
and said no this is not a conversion
this is an adaptation and when you're
doing adaptations you don't need a
soundproof test same Council two
different building inspectors giving you
know two different
crazy isn't it yeah so you saved on that
extra two or three grand that you would
have spent yeah and that's again it just
shows the importance of knowing knowing
your craft but I wouldn't have known
that and even even another soundproof
guy that was speaking to because you've
got to speak to a few people that are
experts in the industry yeah
even he didn't pick it up but when this
second building inspector came he picked
it up okay I've learned something new
there and hopefully all your viewers
have learned something new here right
and it's like you gotta share that
knowledge 100 share it share it share it
why not a lot of people don't though a
lot of people that are in property I
feel like the there's a lot of there's a
very competitive nature oh I'm not
telling you yeah oh no I'm oh I'm gonna
keep that scene yeah nah what you taught
us was tell double exactly you know
share it share your knowledge what have
you got going on at the minute what's in
the pipeline now to do another six bed
HML with ensuites yeah this one's gonna
cost less to do
a bit a bit more to buy it's in a great
location my property is like 500 yards
away from a Premier Inn so thanks
Premier and you've done the market
research exactly yeah because I've spent
10 million building a Premier Inn hotel
yeah I've done the market research all
you got to do now is just get a small
little unit or a small little property
you know that there's demand exactly
make the supply better exactly and the
demand is there and you will make money
yeah clean comfy and convenient right
you know simple
um uh attitude to live by when it comes
to the essays that's what people want
convenience more than anything yeah
speed sells yeah what would be your
greatest advice if you're gonna to leave
people with that are wanting to get the
foot in the door on their first property
get out there learn training first yeah
learn these things hang around with
like-minded people get yourself in
Facebook groups and things like that
there's great groups out there
get yourselves in them ask questions
do it yeah just do it love it well
Muhammad I appreciate you I appreciate
your friendship and um keep on winning
brother yeah always thank you for having
me
[Music]